in the moment we're talking a lot about
reform and the potential now to build
down the carceral state and we've
ignored or overlooked places where it's
rapidly growing and so what we're seeing
now is law enforcement and immigration
enforcement are colliding or converging
where they used to be quite separate
systems and we're essentially
criminalizing the enforcement of
immigration policy so during the Reagan
years we had about twenty or twenty five
thousand deportations a year under
President Obama we've had about 400,000
deportations a year until recently so
it's a dramatic increase in in the
number of people are being deported many
of them being deported back to countries
that they left as children where they
don't speak the language and being
deported for minor violations or for
violations that they committed many
years ago and have not committed a
serious crime since then now what we're
seeing is very similar I feel like we're
living through the 1960s and 70s again
where we criminalized race in the 1960s
and 70s and now this great unease that
we have in this society and anxiety has
landed on immigrants and that's even
prior to Isis and the San Bernardino
killings and things like that and so
we've created this misperception now
that immigrants bring crime and increase
crime rates when the data actually tells
us that immigrant populations suppress
crime rates in gateway cities and in
cities that are not gateways for
gateways for immigrants but smaller
cities they neither suppress nor
increase the crime rate but we've
created this misimpression now that
immigrants are bringing lots of crime to
the United States and are destabilizing
force I think one point it's important
to make is that the largest population
now in the federal prison system are
Hispanics they're the largest plurality
larger than whites and larger than
african-americans
and many of them are there for
immigration related offenses so again
when we try to think about the carceral
state in black/white terms we really
need to think about immigration because
again drug crimes fueled a lot of the
growth of the federal prison system but
immigration crimes are fueling much more
and the other thing to think about
immigration is that if we care about
crime and we care about protecting our
borders prosecuting so many petty
immigration offenses and so punitive Lee
is taking up all the resources of people
on the border many federal prosecutors
will tell you and we've had many studies
done that they're not pursuing the big
drug crimes they're not pursuing the big
money laundering the big trafficking of
weapons in part because so many
resources are going into prosecuting and
taking care of these petty immigration
offenses so that in fact we're keeping
we're making ourselves more vulnerable
rather than less vulnerable by having
you know 80% of our prosecutors time in
their cases being taken up with petty
immigrants at the cost of these much
more serious crimes and threats
you